.
Let us solve more of the issues that are gathered
The concepts we learned in the last two presentations
So let's assume that we have 4x + 3 variance
-1
Let's find all the x values ​​that you achieve
If the first thing I would do better is get rid of this 3
So let's subtract 3 from both ends of this equation
If the left side becomes 4x
This is deleted
This ends up being zero
There is no reason for us to change the disparate yet
We only combine and subtract from both sides
In this case, we ask
This will not change the difference as long as we
We offer the same value
We have -1-3
This equals -4
-1 - 3 = -4
And then will - let us see, we can divide the two ends
This equation is on 4
Divide the ends of this equation to 4
Again, when we multiply or divide the ends
Mixed on a positive number, this does not change
Differentiated
If we have an x ​​in the left side
x <-4 4 4 = -1
x <-1
Or we can write it in the period format
All x values ​​are negative from infinity to -1, but
Not include -1, so we put
Quotations here
Let's solve a harder example
Suppose we have 5x> = 8x + 27
So let's put all the x expressions on the left side, and
The best way to do this is to subtract-8x from both ends
If 8x is offered by both parties
The left side becomes 5x - 8x
This equals -3x
We still have a bigger signal than
We are adding or subtracting the same
Quantities on both sides
These 8x are deleted and we have 27 left
If we have 3x> 27-
Now, all we turn this into x, we have to divide both
The parties on -3
But remember, when we hit or split the ends
Mixed on negative number, reflect
Differentiated
If we divide both sides on -3, we will have to
We reflect these disparities
I will go from a larger signal than
To signal less than
The way I remember the elder of
Is that the left side seems bigger
This is the biggest of
If you imagine this rise, this rise is greater
From that height, it is a point
I do not know if this is bothering you or not
These are less than
This point is less than
The distance of that great opening
So I remember her
But anyway, 3x / -3
So now we have divided both parties on a negative number, ie on
-3, reflect the variance of the larger than
To less than
On the left side, the 3 is deleted
We get x </ 3 -3
Which equals -9
Or a period code, will be all about
Endless to 9, not including 9
If you want to represent them on the setup line
It will look like this
These will be -9, maybe it's going to be
-8, and this -10
It will start from -9, and will not include it, because it is not
We have a signal of equality here, and we take everything less than
So, down, as we see, to infinitely negative
Let us solve a complex issue
Let's assume that we have (8x-5 (4x + 1>
= -1 + 2 (4x - 3)
Now, maybe it looks tough, but if
We simplified it step by step, you will see it is no more difficult than
Any of the issues we have solved
So let's simplify it
We get 8x - - let's distribute this 5
Let me say 8x, and then distribute the 5
-5 × 4x = -20x
5. When I say -5, I am talking about
that's all
-5 × 1 = -5, then this will be
Greater than or equal to -1 +
2 x 4x = 8x
2 x -3 = -6
Now we can combine these two expressions, 8x - 20x =
-12x - 5> =
- We can incorporate constants, -1-6
= -7, and then we have + 8x
Now, I'd better get all the x expressions in the left side
So let's subtract 8x from both ends of this equation
We subtract 8x from both ends of this equation
I am subtracting 8x
This left side, -12-8
= -20
-20x-5
Again, there is no reason to change
Different yet
All we are doing is simplifying the parties, or gathering and
We ask them
The right side becomes - this is deleted, 8x
- 8x = 0--
If we have 7
Now I want to get rid of this
So let's add 5 sides to this equation
Add 5 to the ends of this equation
We have left-side left-20x
These 5 are deleted
There is no reason for us to change the disparate yet
-7 + 5 = -2
Now, we got to an interesting point
We have -20x> =
If this is an equation, or really any kind of
Equations, we will divide both sides on -20
But we must remember, that when we multiply or divide
The two sides are different on the negative number, we have to
Differing reflectors
Let us remember that
If we divide this aspect on -20 and this division
On the 20th side, all I did was take these two sides
And divide them by 20, we have to reverse the disparities
Greater than or equal to become smaller than or
Equal
Of course, these are deleted, and we get x <
= - Negative signs are deleted -
2/20 = 1/10
If we want to write it with a period code, the
The upper limit will be 1/10
They noted, we will complement it, because we have a signal of equality
Less than or equal to, so we will include 1/10, and
We will go down to the minus endlessly
Anything less than or equal to 1/10
This is another way to write
For fun, let's draw the line of preparation
Let's draw a line here
Maybe this will be zero, this is the 1
Maybe 1/10 is located here
Anything less than or equal to 1/10
If we include 1/10 and everything less than it
It will be within the solution set
You can try any value less than 1/10 and
Verify that they will achieve this disparity
.